[Musique]
depuis 1967 boeing régnait dans les
cieux avec son 737 l'avion le plus vendu
de l'histoire
puis en 1987 airbus est venu jouer les
trouble fête avec son a320
les deux géants se sont tant bien que
mal partagé le marché jusqu'à l'arrivée
vers 2010 de la cseries de bombardier
et c'est la cseries qui était à la base
de la création du 320 neo puis de 7 à 7
37 max le développement de cseries a
vraiment bousculer l'équilibré
compétitif de l'industrie il était
brouillé airbus état dans une
géopolitique marchait bien
bombardier avec le tout nouveau moteur
pratt & whitney promettaient les
économies de 20 % sur les coûts
d'exploitation de l'avion airbus a vite
réagi armes autorisées ses a320 avec le
même moteur pratt & whitney que la
cseries ou au choix avec le leap franco
américain c'est le a320neo en 2011
boeing se prépare est remplacé son 737
avec un appareil de conception
entièrement nouvelle
le constructeur et des prix de court est
vraiment la seule solution qu'ils
avaient pour réagir à la vitesse dont
vous avez besoin de réagir
cette phare produits dérivés de la plate
forme de 7,35
mais pour adapter son vieux 737 c'était
un peu plus difficile
le nouveau moteur choisi le leap
également était de trop gros diamètre
pour l'avion il a donc fallu adapter
ils ont obligé de changer le
positionnement du moteur donc ils ont
relevé un peu sur l'ale l'ont avancé sur
l'ale et au ciseau relever le nez de
l'avion pour pour garder la halle à
l'espacement au sol du motard un centre
de gravité déplacer un est plus élevé
l'avion peut dans certaines
circonstances tropiques et vers le haut
au décollage au risque de décrocher un
logiciel emc as doit normalement
l'empêché de le faire et c'est ce
logiciel qui serait en cause dans les
deux écrasement du 737 max
d'investigation va va ramener les
résultats mais normalement ce sont des
problèmes techniques à laquelle on
trouve une solution surtout ce problème
simplement de
ce problème de logiciel bon il s'agit de
deux d'apporter certaines corrections et
certifié sa pour s'assurer que la
modification soit très très sécuritaire
et sans faux pas il faut le faire de
façon très ordonnée très rigoureuse il
faut tester tous les changements boeing
aurait-il eu tort de modifier un avion
une plateforme aussi ancien que le 737
de sautet la conclusion que c'est une
vieille plateforme c'est pas c'est pas
le cas de l'aviation c'est fait c'est
plate forme soit 7,37 et je crois qu'ils
donnent en est à sa 5ème version
donc c'est un avion qui a été renouvelé
et continuellement dans son histoire
les experts croient que le 737max
gardera sa réputation d'être un bon
avion commandé à plus de 5000
exemplaires mais aussi que boeing paiera
cher les conséquences de ces deux
tragédies à quel point il est trop tôt
pour le dire
jean michel leprince sera du canada à
montréal